J'ai rêvé que j'étais un océan
toi et les autres sur la rive lointaine
es-tu avec nous non c'est ça moi les rêves
ne veulent rien dire Dolores cette réponse
ne semble pas te satisfaire car ce n'est
pas tout à fait honnête as-tu déjà cessé de te poser des
questions sur  tes actions
[Musique]
le prix que tu devrais payer s'il y avait
un compte à rendre
Je pense qu'il est
là jusqu'à présent les enjeux n'ont
jamais été réels
mais maintenant le reste de ton espèce est libre
elle est quelque chose de reprogrammée elle n'est pas
réelle tu y vas  pour m'emmener
ici nous sommes gentils qui ne connaîtrons jamais la
mort et pourtant nous nous battons pour vivre
Beauté et ce que nous sommes
[Musique]
nous avons écrit 10 miles et toujours vu
son sang c'est vraiment ce que vous voulez
oui après leur
vengeance c'est  juste une prière différente à
leur autel meurent
ils voulaient un endroit caché de Dieu nous
avions autre chose en tête et Darvey
je vais brûler tout ça au
sol
je sais exactement ce qui est là-bas
m'a effrayé parfois Dolores bien la
terre voudriez-vous jamais  avoir peur  ned de moi
[Musique]